This is the shark tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes of getting
an investment
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
What's your sales
in the last month?
Sales were $5,500.
That is nothing.
The entrepreneurs must
convince a shark to invest
the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
Here's the truth.
You don't have a business.
You have a hobby.
If someone offered you
$3 million today,
you wouldn't take it?
I wouldn't take it, Mark.
You're a fool.
(Stammers) Mark, I--
you're a fool. I'm out.
If the sharks hear
a great idea...
Whoa!
They're ready to invest,
using their own money.
If you're gonna stay
on your path,
you need a big wallet.
Happen to have one.
And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
What is this?
Kevin, give the guy a break.
This is business!
Are we gonna hold hands
and sing "Kumbaya" here?
Shut up, Kevin.
♪♪
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
♪♪
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran
went from waiting tables
in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real estate empire.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
Internet companies
for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner,
the queen of QVC,
holds over a hundred patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing over
a half a billion dollars
in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur, tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas MavEricks.
First into the tank is a mom
from Highland Park, Illinois,
with a product to make kids
feel more safe and secure.
♪♪
Hello, sharks.
My name is Debbie Glickman,
and my company
is Fairytale Wishes.
I am asking for
a $35,000 investment
in exchange for 33%
of my company.
When my son
was a little boy,
he was scared to go to sleep
at night.
So I ended up buying
a teeny-weeny bottle
of $25 lavender pillow spray,
and I told my son
it was a magic potion
that would give him
sweet dreams,
and he bought it,
and he went right to sleep.
And I thought to myself,
you know what?
There's an idea there.
Fairytale Wishes is a line
of magic aromatherapy sprays
to help empower children
through the use of yummy scents
and their imagination.
A couple of sprays of
our signature lavender-scented
sweet dreams spray
on your child's pillow...
(Spritzes)
Will assure your child
sweet dreams
are on the way.
And if your kids have
monsters under the bed...
(Growl)
(Laughter)
Our bubblegum-scented
monster repellent
will keep the monsters
far, far away,
because in case
you didn't know it,
monsters are terrified
of the smell of bubblegum.
(Laughter)
I have some sample pillows
for you.
A pillow for everybody.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Oh, my favorite.
Cotton candy scent.
Thank you, Debbie.
Grape jelly scent. (Laughs)
Grape jelly.
(Robert)
Wow, it smells really good.
They smell good.
Thank you.
I mean, that really smells
like bubblegum, grape jelly.
What does it cost--what does
it cost you to make this?
It costs $2.16 to make.
To make it?
Yeah.
Why is it so expensive?
Because--well, 'cause I make it
here in the United States, and--
and what do you sell them for?
The 4-ounce bottle
has been selling for $9.99.
How many have you sold
over what period of time?
We have been in business
for four years, and last year,
our sales were $5,500.
$5,500?
That is nothing.
What I've learned is that
P.R. is really our key,
because when we see P.R.--
you know what?
I'm just telling you...
Uh-huh?
To me, that is the ultimate
red--red flag.
When somebody thinks
it's all about P.R.,
"if I only got
on one more TV show,"
in one more magazine"--
you're always looking for
a-a shortcut.
Well, I'll tell you what.
We did a 6-store test
with Bed Bath & Beyond,
and in one month,
they reordered three times.
It was during the holidays.
They had it up
in the front of the store.
The minute they put it
in the back of the store,
sales tanked.
Welcome to the real world.
If they didn't reorder,
it's because it didn't make
enough money per linear foot
for them to care about it.
They put another product
in there that sold much better.
Well, they--when they moved it
to the back of the store--
but then what happened--
Bed Bath & Beyond sees
a new Debbie every day...
Right. Right.
With another product.
The only Debbies that get
to stay in sell product.
Yours didn't.
They threw you out.
Here's the truth.
You don't have a business.
You have a hobby.
That's it. Take the rest
of the inventory.
Put it under the bed.
Let the monster eat it,
and forget about this one.
(Laughs)
You know what?
In all due fairness...
That was rude.
Thank you.
I have never, ever gotten
anything
but wonderful, positive
feedback.
No, but that's not true.
Do you know why? Because
the best feedback in the world,
the only feedback
you could trust is sales.
Listen, I'm great at all
the creative stuff,
and I'm not so great
at the business end,
and that's why I came here
to find a partner
to help me
with the business end.
Debbie, I-I think you're
driving meshugge. Honestly.
I don't think you have
a firm grasp
on all the different pieces.
You know, I have to jump in.
I don't agree with Mark.
♪♪
Debbie, I don't think
you have a firm grasp
on all the different pieces.
I have to jump in.
I don't agree with Mark.
I think that this is
very creative.
I think kids probably love it.
I love your creativity
about this product.
Nobody's gonna buy this.
Apparently nobody has bought it.
I think it may need some help.
She's--she said herself,
she's not good at sales.
Some of the monsters
you sprayed four years ago
have died of old age, and you
still don't have any sales.
(Laughter)
You don't have a business.
I'm out.
Don't you have kids, Kevin?
Of course I do.
He eats his children.
Look, I just tell 'em,
if there's any monsters around,
I'll take care of it,
and they believe me.
(Laughs)
Thank you, Barbara.
It doesn't work on him.
I will tell you
what I think would help you.
Okay.
I don't think that
parents and families
need this big of a bottle.
I think if you made
a 5-pack...
Uh-huh.
Of small bottles,
then you have
your monster spray,
the lavender spray...
The small bottle..
Then you buy all 5
for like $7.99.
Are expensive to make.
And then a mother has
something...
They're expensive to make,
though. Right.
Well, you've gotta get
better sourcing.
Right.
But to me,
I just think
a different marketing strategy
might be more helpful.
Right, right.
I think having five flavors--
I don't think is
at all necessary.
You should have
one magic spray, period.
Decide what it is.
Call it "magic spray."
Yeah.
You could make a good product
of this. You're creative,
but you know what?
It's not selling.
So you gotta redo it
and figure out what to do
and I don't wanna take
that ride with you. I'm out.
Okay. Thank you so much.
Here's an idea. Here's an idea
that maybe you'll like.
So I came up with this idea
to partner with Disney, okay?
Disney has
25,000 hotel rooms...
Debbie, have you called Disney?
In the U.S.
Not yet.
(Laughter)
But I'm gonna.
I-I need someone to help
guide me through that end of it.
You know what I'm--
do you know what I'm saying?
(Robert) Oh, come on, Debbie.
Right.
You've got it
into Bed Bath & Beyond,
so don't tell me you couldn't
pick up the phone
and call the other ones,
because you did it once.
Right. No, no, no.
I understand, so--
a goal--Debbie, a goal
is great to have.
Right.
But you gotta have a timeline.
A goal without a timeline
is simply a dream.
Right.
I'm out.
Okay, thank you.
Mark?
Debbie, Debbie, Debbie.
Listen, here's the thing.
I will do anything
in my power
to make this business grow.
Look, most entrepreneurs,
when their back
is up against the wall
and their sales are falling,
that is all that
they can think about.
That consumes them.
That eats them,
and that's the way
you have to be.
You have to work
like there's somebody
trying to take it
all away from you,
because there probably is.
My suggestion is
get somebody else
to sell it for you,
because that is not
your strength.
You're not an entrepreneur.
You're a want-repreneur,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay, well, thank you.
I disagree with you, though.
Who's left?
Lori.
Well, I don't agree
with Mark or Barb
that you need
to go down to one bottle.
They're mistaken because they're
not retail people like I am.
I think your creativity
is fantastic. I love this.
I think it's super sweet.
The problem is, is you haven't
gone and really tried,
I don't think hard enough,
to make your dream come true.
I'm out.
Okay, well,
thank you guys so much
for your time. Thank you.
(Mark) Good luck, Debbie.
(Lori) Good luck.
Thanks.
I believe in my company.
I believe in everything
that it does to help kids,
and I'm not gonna stop.
I'm gonna keep goin'.
♪♪
In season 4, Dave Alwan brought
his specialty meat company,
Echo Valley Meats,
to the shark tank.
Wow.
(Kevin) Wow, that is good.
But the sharks weren't biting
when they discovered
Dave was missing key
information on his business.
Do you know what it costs you
to acquire a new customer?
Um, not really,
to be honest with you.
You're coming in unprepared.
That doesn't cut it. I'm out.
Let's see how he's doing now.
♪♪
Walking away without a deal
was a little tough.
However, the experience
was invaluable
to the success of my business.
The sharks said I was unprepared
because I didn't know
my customer acquisition cost.
Since then, I have become
a better entrepreneur
and become a better businessman
as a result of that.
Because of the advice
I got from the sharks,
I've dug much deeper into myself
and within my company
to become much more efficient,
streamlined.
It's really made us
become a better company overall.
Since airing on "shark tank,"
business has exploded.
Our web site has taken
1,600,000 hits.
We've shipped out
over 6,700 orders,
and orders still continue
to pile in on a daily basis.
It's phenomenal.
287 more orders!
(Cheering)
I have recently finalized deals
with Amazon, Costco, Sam's,
and QVC,
all for Echo Valley Products.
Over the next fiscal year,
we are projecting
between 5 and $10 million
of gross sales.
Being in business 23 years,
(cows lowing)
We have never come close
to numbers like this,
and it's exceeded
any expectations we had.
(Horse whinnies)
I would absolutely like to thank
the sharks for my success.
Their endorsement and praise
over our products
have been nothing short
of a miracle. Thank you.
♪♪
Come on! Let's go!
Go, go!
I'm Nathan Jones.
I'm Erick Jansen.
And we're both firefighters
from Austin, Texas.
Go, go, go!
(Siren wailing)
We met eight years ago
on the job,
and we've been great friends
ever since.
Ready? Go. Careful.
We love spending time
outdoors with our kids.
Aah!
We wanna take 'em
everywhere,
but they can't always
keep up.
Daddy!
Oh, goodness.
So we decided
to invent something
that would help us out.
Aah!
(Whirring)
After breaking
several sewing machines
and testing
countless prototypes,
we finally had our product.
Okay, man. That's perfect.
That's the one, right?
When we're not
putting out fires,
we devote all of our time
to product development
and sales.
We've both invested over $20,000
of our own personal money
to make this thing happen.
We need the sharks' help
to take our product
to its full potential.
If the sharks have a heart
in kids,
they will absolutely love
our product.
♪♪
Hello. I'm Erick.
And my name's Nathan.
This is my son river.
Our company is the freeloader,
and we're seeking $200,000
for a 15% equity stake.
We all know kids
are full of energy,
but sooner or later,
they hit the wall.
A few years ago, I traveled
the streets of Paris
with my then
5-year-old daughter.
Knowing full well
her limitations,
we knew we had to plan
our outings accordingly
to avoid the dreaded meltdown.
Mm-hmm.
I mean, who wants to miss out
on seeing the eiffel tower
just because your kids
get tired of walking, right?
And as any parent knows,
you're gonna end up
carrying your kids
whether you want to or not.
And every time I did,
my arms were on fire.
I would start sweating.
My legs felt like lead.
Man, this was work.
So Erick gets back,
and we start talking.
Surely there has to be
a better way to carry our kids
than what the market
currently has to offer.
What if we made something
that was a lighter weight?
Something that was
more comfortable?
Something that felt like
it wasn't even there?
Sounds impossible, right?
This is what we created.
The freeloader.
Ha!
So the freeloader is...
Wow.
An ultra-sleek child carrier
that has an integrated frame
and a fold-down seat
that can hold up to 80 pounds.
(Click)
It has
a 5-point safety harness
to keep
the little buckaroo in.
(Laughter)
That is so cool.
And it uses current
hiking pack technologies
that evenly and effectively
distribute the weight
across your shoulders and hips
for extended outings.
The freeloader makes
everyday life easier.
From running errands
like going to the grocery store
to going
on amusement park adventures,
or even if your kid
just needs a quick recharge.
We're on the path
to a great new adventure here.
Who wants to hop on
and join us for the ride?
Can--can I try it? Do you mind?
Oh, absolutely, absolutely.
Can I try it with River
on the back?
Yeah.
I just wanna see
how heavy it is.
Absolutely.
That looks unbelievable.
Is that something that a woman
can carry and hold?
I mean...
Yes. My wife is
the biggest proponent of this.
We have a 3 and a 5-year-old.
(Robert)
Yeah. Do you mind, River?
River, smack him in the head
a few times, please.
(Laughter)
(Robert)
See, Mr. Cuban would do that.
He's not very nice.
All right. There you go.
Hop on, river.
Okay. Let's put you in the...
Whoa.
Let's hear it. "Mush, mush!"
Can I stand up?
"Mush."
Wow.
So he is now buckled in.
Oh, you're so cute.
(Robert)
Safe and secure in there?
(Kevin) Wow.
That's our number one priority.
We know a thing or two
about safety.
Yeah? Gimme five. All right.
(Chuckles)
Wow.
Great idea.
Robert,
are you comfortable?
I don't know if I could do it
all day, but--
Does it hurt your back?
Yeah, you feel the pressure,
but I think for carrying a kid,
as a dad,
your other options--
you always go
for the shoulders.
It's shoulders.
The shoulders work.
The piggyback won't ever work.
All right, Erick,
you've convinced me
it's a fantastic idea.
Are you selling it today?
We started a crowdfunding
campaign back in February,
ran it for 45 days,
and raised over $40,000.
Okay.
How did you get involved
in this?
Are you schoolteachers
or something?
Well, we know a thing or two
about carrying people.
We're both firefighters
out of Austin, Texas.
Oh, there you go. All right.
You are? Yay.
I wanted to ask you
about the product itself.
It seems heavy.
I don't think Barb or I
would be able to carry that.
You're used to carrying tanks
on your back.
Sure, sure. Absolutely. Mm-hmm.
So it's something
you're used to.
But if you did
do an injection mold,
it could be minimal weight.
I mean, the possibilities
are endless--titanium,
but then your costs--
carbon fiber.
You have to be realistic what
your costs are at that point.
With the weight, keep in mind,
that's 5 1/2 pounds.
This over here--
the current child carriers
weigh 7 1/2 pounds
and upwards.
(Robert) Nathan, what do you
need the money for today?
$200,000.
You're asking for 15%.
$110,000 would go to making
2,000 units,
and we'd use $90,000
for operating expenses
such as going to
the trade shows.
(Lori) Are you familiar with
all the rules and regulations...
We are.
For child safety?
Oh, yes. Yeah, yeah. Yes.
Have you been doing testing
for that
with an independent lab?
Yes.
Yes, ma'am.
They're firemen, Lori.
Of course.
Okay.
When I look at it,
the first thing I think--I've
got a 4-year-old son named Jake.
And Jake has finally learned
from his car seat
how to undo these, right?
He's gonna unbuckle it,
he's gonna smack me in the head,
he's gonna punch me,
and then he's gonna
unbuckle and fall over.
(Kevin) I don't know. He's
facing your back. How's he--
no, no, no. Trust me.
If he's riding,
he's smacking, he's unbuckling,
and he's climbing.
(Chuckling)
Kevin, it's Mark's children.
You can only imagine.
Right.
I mean--I mean, if you have
a little boy, then you--
then you know.
Yes, I-I do.
Um, he's not able
to unbuckle those, specifically.
Trust me, it's the same
as his car seat.
And what I'm saying
about this is
you shouldn't be using
this money for 2,000 units.
You should use that
for your testing.
Because the worst possible
scenario
is for you to take
$200,000,
invest $110,000 in inventory,
get them out there,
and realize you've got a problem
and you have to take them back.
I-I think that Mark,
shockingly, is right about this.
I don't know if you want
to dump money
into buying 2,000 units.
I think it's a great product.
I think you can continue
to test the market.
How open are you to that?
We're incredibly open to it.
You all are the experts.
You have the resources,
the connections.
Look, guys, you're not even
a product yet, right?
You're--you're
a proof of concept.
You--you're too early
for me to get involved.
I mean, I love what you're
doing, I'll be a customer,
but you've got to take it
further.
You know, like they say, you
gotta crawl before you ball,
and you guys aren't even
crawling yet, right?
And so for that reason,
I'm out.
(Barbara) Here are
my two concerns.
I think this product needs
to be demonstrated to sell.
I see this on a store counter,
and it looks like every other
black thing out there
that you strap on
to your body.
And I'm concerned as to how
it's gonna sell on its own
without the demonstration aspect
of it,
and I think
that's a real liability.
And you know what?
(Chuckles) Most importantly,
I don't think parents want
to carry heavy kids.
I think that window
is so small.
They don't want to,
but we end up doing it.
(Barbara) They don't want to.
Yeah, if you go on a trip.
I agree with you.
But you have to, Barbara.
But day to day?
No, a 7-year-old?
Forget about it.
There's not a dad in America
who hasn't got the look
from the mom.
But you're gonna bring this
with you the whole day
because of one time?
Yes.
I think the window's too small,
so I'm out.
Just to speak to
the market research and testing,
we wear this to a kite festival
in Austin
with over 100,000 people,
and you will get mobbed
by everybody.
We spent two hours there.
We handed out cards.
In the following 24 hours,
we sold over $3,000
worth of units.
(Lori) It's like umbrellas
when it's raining, you know?
Exactly.
Everybody needs one.
Right.
So you should just
stand at fairs
with that on your back
and have them to sell.
Seriously.
And every parent will come up
and buy one.
And you're right. And that's
when the magic happens,
when people get to see it
and touch it and feel it.
Mm-hmm.
But that's where we are
gonna rely on
the skills
of dedicated sales staff,
people that are
well-versed in it.
No, no, no, no, no.
You're not ready
for that yet.
I would love to help you,
because I love firemen.
You risk your lives every day
to save others.
My problem with the product,
though--
I'm worried about
the safety issues with it.
I think this is really clever,
but I'm not sure
if you're gonna have issues
with either passing
safety testing
or liability from consumers.
For those reasons, I'm out.
I'm past all
the manufacturing issues.
I'm gonna make the assumption
within the next year
you'll optimize for weight
and design.
I'm in a different place.
Even if it's perfect today,
I have no idea
what it's going to cost
to actually scale it
and start selling it,
because I don't know
what my customer
acquisition costs are.
Even baby products--
and I used to be in a business
that sold products for children
between the ages of 3 and 5--
we spent hundreds
of millions of dollars
trying to capture the mothers.
It was really expensive.
It never got easier.
And that's a hard road.
I'm out.
I've made a lot of money
by trusting my gut.
My first sense,
when I saw River get on it,
I said,
this is a great product.
And as people started
talking about
all the objections,
all the negatives,
I became less excited.
My best friend Rob
is a fireman,
and so he taught me,
when you go into a fire,
the very first rule is
stay calm.
The second rule is
assess the situation.
I don't think you've assessed
this situation enough.
I think the design needs to be
a little bit better,
the weight--all those issues.
So I don't think this is
a company today.
I think it's a journey.
But I want to go down
that journey with you.
But I see it as a partnership.
$200,000 for one-third.
Um... okay.
You mind if we take
one minute?
If you want to run that risk,
go ahead.
There's a fire!
Yeah.
The fire is burning,
and you're gonna take a minute?
No, we don't. You know what?
We would love to work with you.
Absolutely.
Congratulations, guys.
Thanks, guys.
Thank you so much.
I think it's a great product.
Yeah. Nice to meet you guys.
Thank you so much.
Yeah. Thanks for being
fire guys.
Thank you.
And thank y'all for your time.
But you know what, guys?
It's funny. The other sharks
almost talked me out of it,
'cause they brought up
all these problems,
and I just went back
to the very first reaction.
And I think dads are gonna
have that reaction.
As soon as they see it,
they're gonna get psyched.
Dads'll get it in a heartbeat.
It's easy to get.
Congrats, guys.
Thank you.
Thanks you guys so much.
Good luck, guys.
Thank you.
We couldn't have asked
for a better partnership
with Robert. We really
feel like he gets it.
Um, he's gonna be great
in helping us
navigate the waters and to
get us where we need to be.
Yeah.
♪♪
Next into the tank are
best friends from Los Angeles
with a solution
to a cooking hazard.
♪♪
Hi, sharks. We're two
sassy girls from L.A.
(Chuckles)
I'm Juli, and this is
my best friend
and business partner, Ozma.
We are seeking $50,000
for a 20% equity
in our company.
Our product is
a never-seen-before,
revolutionary cooking
lifestyle convenience product.
One night, we were hosting
a dinner party
for our girlfriends.
The main dish was fish.
After dinner, the girls and I
hit the town
and headed to
a swanky L.A. lounge.
Someone approached me
and told me
my hair smelled like fish.
Ew!
I was mortified,
so I asked the bartender
for a second opinion,
and sure enough,
my luscious locks
did indeed smell like
our main dinner course.
We knew there had to be
a better solution
to this common
stinky problem.
(Both) So...
(Laughter)
We've created the Kookin' Kap.
(Robert, singsongy)
Da-dun!
(Ozma, singsong) Ta-da!
(Barbara) You gotta be kidding.
(Mark) Oh, my lord.
The Kookin' Kap is so easy
to use.
Just put it
right over your head...
Twirl your hair up.
No hair-tying needed.
And...
(Both) Voilà!
(Laughter)
(Both) And one size fits all!
Oh, God.
Wow.
The Kookin' Kap
is the modern version
of the traditional chef hat
that not only
keeps the smell of food
out of your hair...
(Both) It also keeps hair
out of your food!
(Juli) And it's chic
and comfortable.
(Laughs)
The Kookin' Kap saves
any blowout
and keeps your hair
smelling fresh
and looking like you just
styled it.
(Laughter)
(Robert) Whoo!
Hair smell like crap?
(Both) Get a cap!
(Kevin and Robert) Wow!
Let's have one
on Kevin here, please.
Yes! I think you'd look
pretty in pink.
Let me try the pink one.
I like the look.
He wants the pink one.
Yeah, I think you'd
look hot in pink.
You guys are fun.
Have you sold
any of these so far?
(Robert) Ah.
We have sold 1,729 hats.
Thank you, Ozma.
Uh-huh.
In what time period?
Just under one year.
Oh, you look great
in that cap.
Yeah, it feels good, too.
(Lori) Let's see, Kevin.
Yeah.
Juli, make him take that off.
Your sales are gonna go down.
Ah! We want them--
he looks like
little Bo peep.
It does look like
the camera's on him.
Okay, so you sold
a thousand--what was it?
1,729 caps.
At what price?
At anywhere between
$9.95 and $12.95.
Juli, what's the name
of the company? Kookin'--
Kookin' Kap.
It's called Kookin' Kaps.
Is it kookin' karps
or Kookin' Kap?
(Juli and Ozma)
Kookin' Kap.
(Juli) So in addition--
so why does it say "karp"?
It looks like it.
It doesn't--it's not an "r."
It says "Kap"!
(Kevin) It says "karp."
It's "p" for "Kap."
And what's your background?
Well, so...
We work for one of the largest
financial services companies
in the world.
Really?
(Juli and Ozma) Yes.
Doing what?
I actually work
at Ernst & Young
as a manager
in our advisory practice.
I'm a campus recruiter
for our Los Angeles
and San Diego tax practice.
Should I be concerned
about the first thing
I read in the label?
It says, "Caution. Flammable."
Nonflammable.
No, it says "flammable"
right here.
(Robert scoffs)
It does.
It says "flammable."
(Gasps) No!
(Barbara) Yeah.
They must--
so you have mis-labeled,
that's all.
(Robert) That's not good.
That--
yeah, just like "kookin' karps."
(Robert laughing)
No, it's Kookin' Kap.
In addition to the--
(laughs)
Who does your spell-check?
So, Juli and Ozma, how are you
selling these? Online?
Yes. We're selling them online.
So right now,
we're selling them online,
direct to consumer.
And what do they cost you
to make?
They cost us $3.70.
$3.70.
I love you say everything
in unison!
And you're making them here?
(Juli and Ozma) Yeah.
Where do you make
big bucks in this?
I would say either
retail or on TV.
TV? Hang on?
I wish there was a shark
that worked on TV
all the time.
(Kevin) I--
(juli) Who loves to cook!
(Robert speaks indistinctly)
(Robert) Who could it be?
You know what, guys?
This is the perfect
QVC product.
Mark!
I hope Lori carries it.
I think so, too.
But that's not me.
I'm out.
Okay. Thanks, Mark.
(Lori) I'll tell you,
I have one problem with it.
And--
okay.
(Robert) What?
You're adorable,
but somebody could take
a shower cap
and put it on their head, too.
This is so much better.
And stop the smell.
And--
shower caps are
actually flammable,
when this is not,
even though it says--
even though this says it is?
But this is! It says so!
No, it's not, I promise.
And the shower cap is
actually not breathable.
So when--you actually will
get sweaty...
That's the better answer.
And your hair will get sweaty,
um, so it actually just is not--
this you could wear
for hours.
Yeah.
Like, you could cook an entire
dinner party and wear this,
and you'll take it off--
but--
I like that you're
inventing something...
But, juli--
but I don't think there's
an enormous need for this.
When I invest in a product,
I like something
that solves a problem,
and this is a problem,
but I think it's
a small problem.
Lori, it actually
solves two problems.
Not only does it keep
the smell of food
out of your hair, it also
keeps hair out of your food.
(Lori) Mnh.
Ahh!
So it's also
a contamination issue.
Here's the thing--I don't think
if I were making fish at home,
I don't think I'd be going out
dancing right afterwards
or something like that.
Really? Well,
even if you weren't,
you still wouldn't want
the fish to get--
the smell to get in your
hair for the next day.
But couldn't you take a shower?
You know, I've never really
thought about it.
Perhaps I have smelly hair.
I cook most nights.
I don't know. But...
(Chuckling) I just
can't picture... uh...
Uh... cooking with this
on my head.
(Laughs)
And by the way, I think
you two are adorable.
(Both) Thank you.
But it's not the product
for me. I'm out.
Thank you.
Thank you
for your time.
Ladies, I think you're
two beautiful women,
but when you put the cap on...
(Barbara laughs)
You look like
80-year-old grandmas.
No!
So I'm not sure
I want to buy something
for my wife, or my wife
wants to buy something...
She's only gonna wear it
while she's cooking!
That's gonna make her look
like an 80-year-old grandma.
Only when she's cooking.
Ozma, I-I'm out.
Okay.
I love 80-year-old grandmas,
but I don't see
the real need for this.
I'm out.
I think it's ironic...
(Laughter)
That the only person
who is still in
has no hair.
All right,
let's talk numbers.
Yes.
Yeah, you know,
listen, ladies...
(Laughter)
The whole kookin' karp
thing is crazy.
I-I think you're cute,
but this is not a business,
it's a hobby.
Come on. Just ask for her
to give your money back.
Ladies, you're losing him.
No, no, no!
Wait, wait, wait. We can--
sweeten the offer!
Sweeten the offer!
We can sell anything.
(Lori) No, don't.
We can sell peanut butter
and jelly in a steakhouse.
We can sell Kookin' Kaps
to the masses.
Come on!
Oh, my goodness.
Mr. wonderful.
Absolutely not. I'm out.
(Laughter)
You guys keep thinking, though.
Congratulations, guys.
Good luck.
Thank you.
Thank you for your time.
That's awesome.
(Barbara) Pleasure.
Bye.
(Lori) Bye.
They brought a smile
to my face.
♪♪
Next into the tank
is a lifelong entrepreneur
from Sacramento, California,
with a better way
to cook a favorite fast food.
♪♪
(Low-key voice)
Hello, sharks, uh...
My name's Chris Johnson,
and I'm here...
(Excited voice) Boom!
Hello, sharks, my name
is Chris Johnson...
Oh, my God.
Wow!
And I'm the creator
of the rapid ramen cooker,
the world's fastest,
easiest, and healthiest way
to make ramen noodles
in the microwave.
I'm here seeking an investment
of $300,000
for a 10% equity stake
in my company.
Now, many of you
are familiar with these--
ramen noodles.
They're an undisputed
college staple,
and the annual consumption
of these packets
is 95 billion worldwide.
However, surprisingly,
these things don't have
microwaving instructions,
requiring you to make it on
the stove, which is a hassle.
That's why I created
the rapid ramen cooker.
The rapid ramen cooker
is a square-shaped bowl
in the same exact dimensions
of a block of ramen noodles.
All you do is you take
the ramen noodles,
put it inside the cooker,
add water to the water line,
pop it in the microwave
for three to four minutes,
and it makes perfect ramen
every single time.
So here, I got some
cooked ramen right here.
Look how perfect
the ramen is.
Mmm, mmm, mmm.
Stovetop quality
in less than half the time.
My goal is to put
rapid ramen cookers
in the hands
of every single consumer
of ramen noodles worldwide,
and I'm looking for sharks
to join me in that mission.
I'm gonna give you guys
some, uh, ramen cookers
so you can try it out.
You're not gonna give us
the noodles to go with it?
Absolutely.
I'm gonna bring some noodles
to you as well.
Thank God.
I don't have a microwave
here, though.
There you go. (Laughs)
Thank you.
It doesn't come with noodles?
(Chris) It doesn't come with
noodles. It's just a cooker.
And so you can see how
beautifully cooked...
Let me taste that guy.
I'm hungry.
Those ramen noodles are.
Why not just do it,
I mean, the old-fashioned way?
Take a cup,
put some water in it,
you stick it in the microwave,
your pour the noodles in,
you eat it, you go to sleep,
you wake up, recover
from your hangover.
(Laughs)
I've been making it
in the microwave all my life.
Put you never get
the stovetop quality taste.
Sometimes--
you're drunk.
It doesn't matter.
It does.
It does matter.
Other bowls just heat
excess water.
And they're not specifically
designed to cook ramen noodles.
Help me out here.
You got a $300,000 ask,
and I get 10%
of the rapid ramen cooker.
So computed value's
3 million bucks.
Correct.
Now before I put you
in the microwave...
(Laughs)
Explain to me
why that makes sense.
Tell me about your sales
and how much cash you've made.
Absolutely.
In the last three months,
I've done over $164,000
in sales.
Wow.
How much do you sell
the rapid ramen cooker for?
Uh, it retails for $5.99.
(Kevin) Okay, and how much
does it cost to make?
About 75 cents.
And it's all online?
You don't have any retailers
selling this?
Absolutely incorrect.
We went from zero stores
to over 2,500 stores
in the last three months.
Who are the stores?
We are in Raley's,
Albertsons, Safeway,
Winco, H-E-B in Texas.
(Robert) How did you get into
all those stores?
Grinding, man. I just
pick up the phone and call.
Good for you.
I love that.
Chris, is that all you?
Every single, uh, retailer
that I've, uh, landed
was all me.
If this keeps going, why can't
somebody just knock this off?
It's patent pending.
What's patented?
It's the reservoir design
of a container that cooks
ramen noodles.
You seem very bright
and very enterprising to me.
I'd like to hear
about your background.
Well, I've been an entrepreneur
since I was 16 years old.
At 16, there was nothing
to do for teenagers,
so I created dance parties.
Charging 10 bucks a head,
I was making $4,000
in just one event.
At 19 years old,
I had
my own modeling agency.
When I got out of college,
I started
my own staffing company.
Uh, with zero revenue,
did over a million dollars
in less than 14 months.
What happened to that business?
That business
is still rolling.
Do you own it?
I still own 100%
of that business.
You still running it?
Well, what I did is
I hired my long-term employee,
uh, to run the day-to-day
operations of that company,
and I've been focusing 100%
on rapid ramen.
To me, that suggests
that all you've done
is jump from
quickie business
to quickie business
to quickie business,
because either you lose interest
or you can't run the business.
Absolutely not, Mark.
With the staffing company,
when we hit this recession,
uh, it was the biggest hit
my--I've ever experienced
in my life.
Fair enough.
Look, I feel your pain, right?
Everybody got hit.
Continued to happen.
Uh, staffing company
has not recovered.
But what I understood is that I
could not part-time this thing.
I had
a huge opportunity here,
so I put all my focus
on rapid ramen.
What's your sales
in the last month?
About $80,000.
And what percentage of that
was through retailers?
About 80% is retail.
My projections
with just safeway alone--
you know,
just selling one a day.
Right now in winco,
we're selling three a day,
21 units a week.
You are?
What does that look like
for the whole year?
For the whole year,
we're--we're expected
to do over $2 million
this year.
Okay, so something's
not adding up here.
It doesn't compute.
Yeah, I'm having a problem, too.
If you're doing $80,000 a month
with huge margins,
you should be generating,
you know,
very quickly $300,000
in cash flow
to reinvest in the business.
Right now I have over $150,000
in receivables.
But I look
at our bank account.
It's--we're just
turning through the pro--
through our inventory.
So you need capital
for inventory.
We need capital
You need $300,000 right now?
Based on our projection,
we may even need
a little more than that,
but I-I take it off
the $300,000
because I do have receivables
coming in.
So your expectation is
if I give you $300,000 today
and you need another million
tomorrow, I'm gonna fund that?
I hope you have the wherewithal
to do that.
I think what happens here is
you wanna run with this thing,
sell as many as you can
till you burn it out.
That's basically it.
Well, that's not--
because there
will be competitors
that come in at a lower price
and squeeze that margin
down to pennies.
There's nothing proprietary
about this.
I understand you have a patent,
but a small modification
will do the same thing.
You understand that.
Which leads to the question,
how did you get
to your valuation?
We're gonna do $2 million
this year.
You hope.
Yeah, it's hard to see--
I don't hope, mark.
(Kevin) Well,
of course he hopes.
I'm--I'm--yeah.
You hope, just like when
you had your staffing business.
I'm sure things were great,
and you projected out
a whole lot more.
Just like when you had
your model business.
What you're really saying is
your business is worth
$3 million
on what, $200,000 in sales?
Well, I'll tell you this.
If I were offered $3 million
today to sell the company,
I wouldn't sell it,
based on the growth
that we're having.
If someone offered you
$3 million today,
you wouldn't take it?
I wouldn't take it, Mark.
Un-un-undeniably,
I wouldn't take it.
You're a fool.
I wish I had the courage.
Mark, I--
you're a fool. I'm out.
I don't know
if I like your plan
to burn up all my cash
in inventory.
'Cause one day, what happens
to products like this is,
they stop selling.
And whatever's sitting
in the warehouse,
you own it,
and you gotta eat it.
If you're gonna stay
on your path,
you need a big wallet.
Happen to have one.
(Chuckles)
All right?
So here's an offer
I'll make for you, okay?
I think it may be
the only offer you get.
I will give you your $300,000.
I want $1.10...
Ha!
Every time you sell one
until I get my cash back,
because I don't know
how long it's gonna take you
to sell 300,000 units.
And after I get my cash back,
I get 50 cents in perpetuity.
Chris, this product's gonna last
about two years, maybe three.
What equity are you taking?
Zero equity.
I don't want any equity.
That is a real offer,
and I think that actually
encapsulates the risk
I've got here.
I need to get
this capital back
before this little fad ends,
my friend. That's--
I'll tell you, I think
even for you, back when
you were eating in college,
they ate ramen noodles,
and so--
hey, I ate ramen noodles.
I get it.
Yeah.
But I didn't need to spend
5 bucks to get this bowl.
I figured it out on my own.
Well, I think
that you are fantastic.
I personally am concerned about
somebody else trying to do this.
That's one of my worries
for you.
So I'm not going to
personally invest.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
I--thank--
I appreciate you.
Chris, I tasted this,
fully expecting it to be mushy,
because I have tried
to save three minutes
on many occasions in
sticking it in the microwave,
and it doesn't work.
This tastes exactly the same
as if I cooked it on the stove.
But I'm not totally sold this is
gonna make you a ton of money.
It's a onetime sale.
I feel badly saying "no" to you
because I like you a lot.
I feel like Lori, for God sakes.
"I like you a lot."
(Laughs)
But I'm out.
Chris, I love the story
how you got here.
I love the fact you did it
on your own.
A guy offered to buy my company
for $5 million.
I thought it was all the money
in the world.
I came home. I told my wife
I'm taking the offer.
I had the papers,
and my wife said, "why?
You don't believe in yourself
enough?"
I turned the offer down
because my wife believed in me
more than I believed in myself.
I'm gonna start crying.
And a few years later,
I sold it for $100 million.
Chris,
my only issue with this is
I can't get over the value
of the business today--
Robert, are we gonna hold hands
and sing "Kumbaya" here?
$300,000. The business
is not worth $3 million.
Shut up, Kevin.
What is this?
The business is not worth
$3 million today.
Help me get there.
♪ Kumbaya ♪
Oh, stop it.
Kevin, give the guy
a break.
This is business!
Get to it!
I know. Take it seriously here.
This is business.
This is the guy's life.
This is his life.
Give him a chance.
Every store that I've contacted,
I've been able to get in,
and they're selling,
and they're moving product.
Chris, I wanna be in business
with you.
Here's what I'm comfortable
with today.
I'll give you the $300,000
for 40%.
Wow.
That's giving you
a pretty good value
for a new company, and really,
I'm taking you at your word
because I think you're gonna
make it happen.
So you have two offers now.
You've succeeded where many
other people have not
in "Shark Tank."
What are you going to do?
♪♪
Three sharks are out,
but Chris has two offers--
$300,000 for a royalty
of $1.10 per unit,
which drops to 50 cents
once the investment
is paid back to Kevin.
And $300,000 for 40% equity
from Robert.
So you have two offers now.
Uh, if you don't mind, I'd like
to make a call and, uh--
you understand the nuances
of both offers?
Yeah, yours is to basically
hook me around the throat,
and--and...
(Laughter)
So I'm very clear
about that.
I've been around a long time,
my friend.
I've seen these fads
come and go, and I'm not saying
this will go soon,
but I don't know.
So I'm reflecting it
in the offer.
He's taking out
his risk screening in the--
in the form of 40%
of your company.
If you succeed,
that's a whole lot.
So have some respect for money.
Well, no,
and I-I-I appreciate it.
I've done it my way.
Robert's done it his way.
Now go make a decision.
Okay.
Thank you.
I'll be right back.
I think you're asking
for too much.
We gotta get some cash
along the way.
Come into my deal, and I'll drop
the royalty in perpetuity
down to 40 cents,
but I'm keeping it a buck 10.
I like the fact you're
getting cash along the way.
Yes.
Uh, Mr. wonderful offered me
a deal that wasn't so wonderful.
(Chuckles)
Uh, as far as a royalty that
exceeds the cost of the product,
uh, but no equity.
And then, um, Robert offered me
40% of the company,
which just is outrageous.
Kevin, let's lower
the dollar amount per product
and lower the equity.
Okay, we're gonna drop it down
to 70 cents?
Let's take it to 25% equity
and lower it to 75 cents.
Okay, and what's
the perpetual royalty?
Is that gonna be--
there's no perpetual royalty?
Well, that's the equity.
Right. No, no--
the equity--
you want the equity
and you want the royalty.
Yeah. I think
there's a lesson.
Leaving the tank
lets the water swirl.
♪♪
All right, uh,
thanks for waiting.
Mr. Wonderful,
as far as your--
that--that offer--
well, I wanna tell you,
Robert and I decided
to get together, because we see
merits in both of our deals.
(Robert) Yeah.
I like the idea of getting
some money along the way,
but I like having equity also.
So here's the good news.
We're gonna go in it together.
We've lowered the equity amount
down to 25%, and we've lowered
the royalty to 75 cents
until we get the $300,000 back,
and after that,
25 cents off every box.
It reflects the risk
in your deal,
and it provides you
with the capital you need,
and one way or another,
you're gonna have to
capitalize this business.
Well, well, it siphons the cash
as we're growing.
Let--let me ask a question.
Tell me what you think
is the most realistic number
that you can do
for the $300,000?
For the $300,000, the--
the worst I would go is 20%.
Okay, but, Chris,
I look at the risks.
I want my capital back sooner
than you wanna give it to me.
So I'm putting a mechanism
in place,
and Robert and I both agree.
I wasn't hot on the equity.
He is.
So we've married
these two offers together
to reflect both
of our interests
and provide you
with the capital you need.
Yes or no, Chris?
This is your moment. Yes or no?
I can't accept that offer
at 25%.
Chris, I'll give you
the $300,000
that you're looking for.
I thought you were out.
Nope.
I'm gonna do it
a little bit differently.
I'm gonna be creative,
unlike some of these guys.
$150,000 for 20% of your company
for the equity,
and I'm gonna give you
$150,000 loan.
And I'm gonna price it
the same I do
for growth loans for all
my "Shark Tank" companies.
Right? Which is
significantly less--
you know what?
The offers are
practically identical.
No, they're not.
Because you're paying back
the debt
that we're providing you
in a different way.
Chris, the beauty of the deal
with royalty--
it's just a different form
of interest.
Completely different.
You know we're
highly motivated
to give you more money.
Completely different.
And you have no debt.
You only pay it on the success
of sales.
Completely--
no, here's where--Chris.
You have debt.
You owe this guy $150,000.
That is forever
until you pay it back,
and if it doesn't work out,
he owns the rapid ramen cooker.
That's the evil of debt.
But the difference--
the difference is if
your growth is explosive,
like you think
it's going to be,
that royalty becomes much more
expensive than the debt.
Look, Chris,
we gotta make a decision.
Uh... Mark, if you could do
the $150,000 loan,
and the $150,000,
uh, equity for 15%,
you have yourself a deal.
♪♪
And you know, I'm gonna be
the one grinding,
I'm gonna be the one
making it happen.
I will outwork every single
one of your entrepreneurs.
♪♪
You know what?
Let's go.
Awesome.
(Barbara) Good.
(Lori) Good deal.
(Barbara) Great decision.
Let's go.
Good work.
Appreciate it, man.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you, guys.
Congratulations.
(Barbara) Good luck.
Uhh!
Making a deal with Mark Cuban
is huge for me,
'cause I know to build wealth,
it's all about proximity.
You hang around
four broke people,
you'll be the fifth.
You hang around even just
one billionaire,
that proximity can impact
your life.
(Laughs)
I'm very happy about that.